after 8 years of this prime minister
housing costs have doubled Toronto is
the worst housing bubble in the world
and Canada has the worst mortgage bubble
in the entire o oecd after eight years
of his policies that's why nearly 4
million people on X alone I watched my
groundbreaking and much acclaimed
documentary housing hell how we got here
and how we will get out will the Prime
Minister become the 4 millionth Canadian
to watch this documentary so he can see
a common sense plan to reverse the
housing hell that he's
caused on this side we're making
historic investments in housing we're
linking public transit dollars to
housing density and we're working with
cities to modernize and accelerate the
way we build homes while the
conservative leader focuses on
clickbaits and Views were focused on
building homes for Canadians it's funny
he released a video the very same day
him in a starter home of pretending that
he was a real estate agent but in
reality everyone laughed because they
know that he's doubled the housing cost
I'm putting partisanship aside and
offering the Prime Minister and the
liberal caucus a private screening of my
documentary will the Prime Minister put
his ego aside and join with me
personally to take in this documentary
housing hell how we got in and how we
get out of it the reality Mr Speaker is
the conservative leader continues to
call for the federal government to get
out of the business of Housing and we
will not repeat the same mistakes he
made when he was housing Minister under
Steven Harper while the conservative
leader focuses on clickbait and Views
we're going to focus on building
Canadians more homes that's right did
try to make a video it was a total
failure his videos don't get clicks and
his houses don't have bricks after 8
years if he would just take 15 minutes
away from his photo ops he can watch my
brilliant documentary on X or YouTube
but he has demonstrated that he's
extremely satisfied with his ability uh
to spread misinformation and
disinformation online which yes I will
admit he's very good at we're focused on
building more housing for Canadians not
focused on self-aggrandisement like the
leader of the opposition he is the king
of
self-aggrandisement as evidenced by the
fact that he's now attacking my much
acclaimed document when he claims he
hasn't even watched it how would he know
Mr Speaker when I came into question
period today I didn't think it' be an in
I'd be hearing an infomercial for how
great P paie of social media skills
sorry the
leader well well we'll back up I mean
The Honorable prime prime minister knows
he's not supposed to use the the names
of members of parliament The Honorable
right honorable prime minister thank you
Mr Speaker I apologize I didn't think
Canadians were going to be hearing and
in commercial for the leader of the
opposition's YouTube page